c'est quoi ce coup d'essai ce week-end
mais moi j'ai travaillé sur koh lanta
tout vendredi avec grenoble et votre
mari ça a été bah ouais l'hôtel très
bien très bien oui mais quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean masson vous passez vous franchement
il est frais je peux ni je bénis ça y
est emballé la brigade à 14h tél jean on
a gagné ou quoi il a fait la vitrine de
l'art ou la vendée je prends deux
orteils en plus mais tu es bénisse les
pieds sont dits non sur ma mère très bon
pied ah bah tu es le pied d'ailleurs
mais confirmé sa confiance de grèce on
dirait qu'on dirait du potin dans bernie
il est plutôt là bas ça se voit tout cas
c'est très sympa mais dites moi monsieur
qui met pas sa langue les jours comment
votre avis est il mieux mes preuves
indirectes commandes à l'éprouvant
toulouse
[Applaudissements]
alors mes paroles
les portables aux garçons hommes --qui
peut le billet tu amènes encore pas de
quoi tu es tu n'as mais aussi la
propagation des frais sur mobile et pogo
ça allait enlever le hall embrasse et
prochain fait un très beau couple est
très performant lui points apparemment
ça rappe avec moi du tout trouvé du tout
d'accord ces jeux vie celui qui arrive
plus forts à jean michel mr exactement
merci